هنا حيث القسوه تشمل الاحياء والقتلى قرار
المحتاجين الايرانيين بمواصله طريق
التظاهرات الشعبيه ضد النظام الايراني
تقابله السلطات باصدار احكام قاسيه بحق
المتظاهرين ليس ذلك فقط بل تستولي عالجت
من القتلى هذا بخلاف احكام القضاء بالسجن
لسنوات طويله والجلد للمحتاجين التي تصفها
مؤسسات الحقوقيه دوليه بالمحاكمات السوريه
تقارير حقوقيه تصدر يوميا محذرا من اوضاع
المعتقلين احدثها ما نشرته لجنه متابعه
اوضاع المحتجازين التي اكدت الاقيها
معلومات عديده عن اجراء محاكمات عبر
الانترنت للمتظاهرين المحتجزين ليس ذلك
فحسب اللجنه تنبه من اقتصار تلك المحاكمات
على القاضي والموقوف وما يضاعف من مخاوف
اللجنه المده الزمنيه الوجيزه للمحاكمات
الافت التي تحرم بدورها المحتجزين من اي
فرصه لدفاع عن انفسهم كما تعدموا اي امال
امامهم بالتواصل مع محامهم وحتى اللحظه
تصدر احكام الاعدام وسط مخاوف جديه من سعي
نظام الى تنفيذ الاعدام بحقه 26 موقوفا
لديه وفق منظمه العدل الدوليه ورغم
الاذنات الدوليه لما يوصف ببطئ النظام
بالمحتاجين
نقلت وكاله انباء وشطاء حقوق الانسان ان
عدد ضحايا الاحتجاجات منذ ان انطلاقات
يفوق 500 شخص بينهم نحو 70 قاصر في ما
يتجاوز عدد المعتقلين في سجون النظام 20
الف ايراني حنان المصري العربيه